hi I'm zebulon Cooper the winner of the
2010 Nebraska State Geography Bee from
Prague Nebraska if I could trade places
with any famous explorer I would trade
places with Zebulon Pike an explorer of
the American Southwest in 1806 he
explored and drew maps of the area just
like I like to draw maps however I would
trade back to being me before he got
captured by the Spanish a kolaches a
fruit filled pastry that comes from the
Czech Republic guess we're the largest
one was made yes right here in Prague it
weighed fifty two hundred pounds if I
was given a ticket to go to anywhere on
earth I would go to New Zealand to see
the shores on the coast the pastures
were sheep outnumber humans 12 to one
and the snow-capped mountains could
always win behind you
whether they are real or fictional
drawing maps can help you prepare for
the B you don't have to be artistic sand
do this just as long as you see you get
the main places cities and rivers here
we are in Nebraska and if you come here
you might see some a lot of farm ground
and a few thunderstorms the one right
here I better hit on in
you